hello and welcome to this workshop on
building a REST API with node express
and [ __ ] well let's begin with the
agenda for today we're going to start
with touching upon some of the concepts
related to this topic followed by the
installation of the environment and we
will start with setting up the
application before we dive into the crux
of this workshop which is to set up a
express web server and then we're going
to connect it to MongoDB we have
Mongoose and I have a bit of a stretch
here if we have time I want to show you
how to deploy this application using a
service called now ACH so let's start
with concepts around HTTP rest and api's
so what does HTTP it stands for
hypertext Transfer Protocol
now hypertext is basically text that can
link to other text hence the word
hypertext Transfer Protocol because
that's being transferred it's an
application layer protocol it's built on
top of the tcp/ip protocol what that
means is it's using tcp/ip for
communicating but then there's
application layer logic on top it pretty
much defines all the rules for
transferring resources between a client
and a server now every HTTP request is
executed independently so on the server
side it does not have knowledge of any
of the requests that came before it and
that's what makes HTTP stateless but
there's an interesting thing it's built
on top of T
CPI P which is not stateless so how does
that work basically when you send an
HTTP request its issuing a connection
via tcp/ip to the other side it could be
a server or decline and the tcp/ip
connections stay is connected HTTP will
send what it needs to and then it's
going to disconnect hence it's known as
stateless one of the cool things about
HTTP is that you can transfer anything
in the body as long as the HTTP headers
define what is being transferred so for
instance if you have an image versus
HTML file versus a JavaScript file
embedded in your body then you need to
specify the content type in the header
and that's how the receiving end knows
what to do with it now let's talk about
rest it stands for representational
state transfer it's actually an
architectural pattern with design
guidelines HTTP is usually the
underlying protocol when you're
implementing rest but rest can be
implemented on other protocols it hasn't
been used as much though what HTTP
provides us is basically a set of
methods that need to be used explicitly
by the rest pattern every restful
resource has a unique ID which makes it
interesting because you can reference
different things over the internet via a
specific URL
now client state is not persisted
between requests so that's what rest
basically states that we should be doing
however that state can be passed along
to the server via some attributes that
help the server decide how to process
that request rests also states that the
application should define a caching
policy for responses what that means is
it allows the client to you make a
decision on the received content and
they can decide to either keep it in
their cache and serve it from there for
subsequent requests so that it improves
the application performance it also
dictates that they should be separation
of concerns between the clients and
servers what that means is the client
does not care about what is the memory
usage on the server or what the setup is
of the hardware and things like that and
vice versa that's also a layered system
so the client doesn't really know if
it's talking directly to the host server
or if there are other intermediate
servers such as proxy servers or edge
cache servers and things like that
now let's talk about what an API is it
stands for an application programming
interface basically you have functions
that are defined on the server side and
the API tells you what is supported from
the server and where the requests should
be made so essentially it's going to
tell you what the the pattern of the
urls are that you're going to call it
use the call in to the server
pretty much it's telling you what the
format of the request and response is
now there's no standard way of writing
api's and that's what makes it somewhat
powerful
but at the same time it's a bit scary
because you know that every system will
vary so much and so that's where rest
comes in it provides us with guidelines
on how these api's should be constructed
you're going to hear about something
called a crud operation over and over
when you're using rest and all that
stands for is it's an acronym for
creating reading updating and deleting
records so essentially when you're
making a call over an API you're
performing one of those four operations
anyway let's get started with the
installation
I had a note about this in the workshop
description so hopefully you are all set
up with this but I quickly want to touch
upon what this entails so we need an IDE
where we're going to write code you need
no GS installed usually NPM is part of
the no GS installation so you should be
good there we're gonna use an instance
of a [ __ ] database in the cloud via an
lab comm and then one of the things I
mentioned forgot to mention was that we
need a rest client I'll get into the
details there something like insomnia or
postman and then finally Robo treaty
which allows us to look at the data in
[ __ ] so as for the IDE you have three
different options vs code atom and
webstorm that I would recommend but
there are a ton of IDs out there you
want to find something that's going to
help you with the language and the
framework that you're working with and
all three of these are very powerful and
customizable as far as nodejs is
concerned you can get any latest version
of nodejs and we should be good that
should have two leaders package manager
there is a subtle difference so if you
have version 5 you
need to use a save command because it
automatically saves everything in the
package when we install any of the
packages and then as far as coding today
we're going to use the natively
supported es6 and seven that's available
in node that way we don't have to setup
babel or any other transpilers if you
can go to node green you'll notice that
it lists out all the features that are
supported by node and this gives you a
good idea of which version supports what
feature in es6 and seven
sorry we're trying to figure out the
video here in some reason it's not
running just give me a moment here I'm
not sure what's going on there
Lana anyway let's continue for now so
MongoDB can be installed locally or you
can get an instance via the EM lab clout
and at the same time if you are a fan of
docker you can use docker to deploy it
somewhere or or install it locally as
well we're going to use M lab for this
workshop because it allows us to easily
deploy the application and not worry
about a [ __ ] installation during
deployment as far as the rest line goes
we're going to use it to test the API
that we build and I prefer insomnia
because it's pretty lightweight but
postman is also very powerful now I got
a question here about if I have any
experience with web storm and what do I
think of it so I've used several IDE s
over the years years actually 20-some
years and I really love web storm
because it allows you to do things that
most of the other IDs require you to
configure it from scratch like vias code
for instance there's one subtle aspect
of vs code that I dislike compared to
web storm and that is you cannot get
multiple console windows in a tabular
view they have sort of a drop-down and
so you can quickly switch between those
windows and I'm sure there's a plug-in
out there but I haven't found that yet
as far as sorry there's another question
here which says things like M lab seemed
way more popular in node world do you
have any thoughts over
this is the case compared to other
ecosystems
I believe [ __ ] is an integral component
of most node applications mainly because
you're coding in JavaScript all the way
from the browser to the backend and it
lends itself very well to [ __ ] as well
because you're storing JavaScript
objects or JSON and then that what that
means is you don't have to go through
conversions for your data compared to
other databases now using my
specifically they have a very good
anaphase and they provide you with a
free starter database that you can get
anything up and running within a minute
literally so it's naturally the
preferred option because it saves you a
lot of time from having to configure it
getting back to this if you guys can
download insomnia or postmen you should
be able to follow along with testing the
API now as far as getting started we
need to set up the application first so
that we can start the code PAP is so
we're gonna start with creating a
project folder and then you will open up
your IDE either whatever it is you're
using in that project folder and then
we'll start to construct other
subfolders and files there so what I'm
going to do is I have a slide outlining
what we're going to accomplish and so I
will keep switching between the slide
and webstorm as we complete these tasks
so in this case we are initializing our
note
and then creating a very very basic
hello world script actually and we're
gonna set up some startup scripts that
allow us to run our application and then
we'll build from there so here is my
webstorm instance I have a folder that's
created here what I'm going to do is in
the console at the bottom here I'm not
sure if I can increase the font in the
console but I will under code what I'm
going to type is NPM in it and I just
want to make sure I'm in the correct
folder here I am okay so I will type an
NPM in it and then I will provide an
option for our optional parameter called
- Y which stands for simply don't ask me
any questions just generate the package
JSON file this is what NPM init will do
is it will create a package JSON file
under your folder and it has a few
attributes there that define what this
project is going to contain especially
if you were turning it into a package
that you wanted other people to consume
that's where some of these attributes
come into the picture so in addition it
also allows you to set up some scripts
that he can run as NPM commands and
we'll get to that in a bit so let's
start out by creating a folder under a
root and call it a SRC which stands for
source now under the source folder we're
going to create another file a
JavaScript file and we're gonna call it
index dot JSP most IDs if you leave out
the extension it will automatically
create it
and let us simply type in a console log
statement here and we will call it hello
world I'm going to save this file and
then go down to the console and I can
run it by typing in note and then
pointing to the file so it's under the
source folder slash index is and there
you go you will see a print hello world
so pretty much it has executed this file
that we created very simple now let's
make this a little more let's add a
helpful command to to our package Jason
so that we don't have to keep pointing
to the file and typing in node source
index so what I'm going to do is modify
the scripts section of package Jason I'm
going to add a command called start and
what we're gonna put in there is the
exact same command that we typed at the
bottom of the window here and this runs
relative to the project root I'm going
to save that I will clear my console and
I'm going to run NPM start notice that
it tried to run it ran our command here
and then you'll see the output at the
bottom so start and tests are two
commands that you can run via an NPM
without an intermediate keyword called
run so normally most of the commands
require you to type in NPM run and then
the name of the command so NPM run start
works as well except for no one made it
a little easier
sorry NPM made it a little easier by
allowing us to just do NPM start very
well switch back to our presentation
window here
all right so hopefully everyone's caught
on to that next let's get started with
Express Express is an NPM package and it
is basically a lightweight web server
what that means is it's taken all the
nodejs HTTP classes and added a layer on
top of it
so that it can communicate or so that it
allows you to communicate via restful
endpoints let's start out by installing
the Express dependency and then we're
going to reference the library and
create a very basic Express application
so going back to the console here I'm
going to type in MPM install Express and
if you're using NPM version 5 and above
it automatically saves it to your
package Aysen so look at my package ace
in here and you'll notice that there's a
dependency section that showed up and
what this means is that when the project
is running it's going to have Express
available to it next we're going to
switch over to the index TS and you can
get rid of the console log here let's
start out by referencing the Express
library so we're going to type in let
Express equals to require Express next
we want to create an application so
we're going to call it app equals
Express and you can open and close
brackets and that creates an Express
application so one of the things we want
to do now is have this Express
application serve some content so let's
start out by
serving some static files so I'm going
to create a folder under under the root
and I will call it public this is where
we're going to store static resources
like HTML files your images JavaScript
CSS and things like that so let's create
an HTML file here I'm going to call it
index.html let's give it a title and
then in the body we'll put in some text
now save the file and go back to index J
s so the way you can serve static
content in Express is via a function
called express dot static so I'm going
to tell Express to use this specific
static file handler this is also known
as a middleware and it's built into
Express so what I can do here is express
that static and then I will pass in the
name of the folder that I want to serve
content from and that's public this is
relative to the root of the project and
finally we won't express to listen to to
a port on the machine so we're going to
do something like this actually let's
create a variable here and I'll tell you
in a moment why so let's call it
constant port and we can read this port
value from the environment variable it's
something that's defined on the command
line before you sort the project
and or if that's missing we can
substitute 3000 for it so I'm going to
do process dot E and B which is
Environment dot port and then if that
does not exist we're going to default to
3000 so I will substitute this 3000 here
with the value port and then let's
simply I'll put a message that says
server I'm going to use these back takes
here so I can introduce a variable in
there and let's call this server has
started on the port that it's actually
running on so that way we know where the
server is running oops I missed the end
there all right so we're gonna go back
and run the server here again by calling
node I'm sorry how we have the script
commands we're gonna do NPM start and
there you go
you see that a message that says server
has started and notice that the program
is still running that's because the the
server is running and it's not going to
release control until we stop it and the
way to stop it is to push control C
anyway let's switch over to a browser
window and what I'm going to do is try
to sorry
that's three thousand and so there you
go you'll see the message that we typed
into the HTML file so this is very
simple it allows you to actually put any
file into public folder and you can
serve it through through a URL here so
essentially what this is doing is
defaulting to index.html the file that
we created so if I type this path it
still loads the same content all right
so now I'm gonna switch back to our
slides here and so we've accomplished
these things here let's move on to the
next which is actually I had a slide
here for serving static content so we're
essentially we created a public folder
under root an HTML file and we
configured express to serve that static
content now let's get on to something
more interesting we're going to create
our first API endpoint and API endpoints
are usually set up with HTTP verbs so
you may have heard about something
called a get request and what that's
essentially doing is making a call to
the server as with the get keyword and
the server is responding with some
content we'll also talk about a couple
of other attributes in that request
called request parameters and query
parameters so let's head over to
webstorm again and what I'm going to do
is create a folder under source called
routes and then let's create your file
called person GS
we're going to create what's called a
route in Express there basically you can
consider them as many applications and
there are advantages to it and I will
talk about it in a bit so essentially we
want to start out by referencing Express
here followed by a router from that
Express instance and then towards the
bottom of the file we're going to export
that router what that allows us to do is
now import it in the index.js file now
let's go ahead and add sorry the route
we were talking about earlier and I'm
going to call it person so we're making
a call to get a personal object here and
usually a route has a callback method
that gets called when you when you make
that request so in this case it's going
to have two parameters a request and
response and then we're going to do
something with it so let's do something
very simple here my Express makes things
easier for us some of these things you
see here are things we would have to
code normally and and in this case it
allows us to do something very simple
like send a message here so let's call
this you have requested a person
essentially this is a route that we've
created that can be accessed via
localhost colon 3000 slash person and
that's what it's going to respond with
now before we go back to the browser and
try this we want to go into the index
file and then reference that file that
we just created so
let's call it person route equals
require oops we're going to go into the
routes folder slash person you don't
need to specify the OJS extension and
then finally we're going to tell Express
to register this route oops
person Rock all right now notice that we
have to go down here now and and stop
the server and restart it because it's
not going to pick up the changes that we
just mean automatically anyway so I just
rethought the server here we're going to
go to the browser again and call that
route when we just created so localhost
3000 slash person and there you go
that's how simple it is to create an API
endpoint of course this is a very basic
version of that now before we continue I
want to do a couple of things here I
want to show you how to use this tool
called insomnia or you may have
installed something called postman so
essentially this allows us to test the
api's that we are creating so let's go
ahead and create a request here I'm
going to call it get person and it's a
get request you can change this later on
so if you get the wrong thing there it's
okay
you can go up here and change it to a
different kind of request one of the
things I forgot to mention was that crud
operations map to for requests you have
to create which happens on a post the
read which happens on a get the update
happens on put and delete happens on
delete
so we have a question here when wood
changes be picked up automatically and
when do you need to restart the server
coming from rails world wondering about
how things are different so we need to
set up a command and in a reference a
library that will monitor our project
for changes so we'll do this right after
the insomnia piece we're looking at but
the the changes I picked up based off
the files that I monitored any sort of a
change in that file once it's saved will
restart the server is insomnia better
than postmen so I started out using
postman and I haven't touched it in a
while so I don't recall exactly but from
what I remember post insomnia was a lot
easier to work with it was much more
intuitive in many ways compared to
postman I think postman might have
improved they do have a lot of advanced
features to that I don't think insomnia
does but for our purposes here the
insomnia works just fine this is
actually what I use on a daily basis and
I haven't gone back to postman in a few
years now so we wanted to talk about
accessing the person route so what I'm
going to do is put in the URL for our
server and then in this case we're going
to call person and I can either enter or
click send here and there you go this
allows us to define all the different
routes that we've created and test them
out over here one of the things that
postman lets you do is generate test
cases from these routes and they have
additional tooling there so I would
definitely encourage everyone to check
out both these tools I think postman is
definitely valuable sometimes I find it
a bit too bloated but they're both very
similar so in this case I think
what REST API I'm sorry what get person
we allows us to do here and insomnia is
also generate some code that we can then
test out through node or any other
project so I'm gonna click on that real
quick and then notice that it has a
bunch of languages here and so
essentially you can pick something so
let's say we were doing this in no GS
then I have the option of choosing which
type of library that it's using to make
that request and I generally would
choose request because it's the shortest
piece of code here and it's essentially
sending some attributes here and then
making that request to the endpoint and
I can copy this and then paste it in my
test file and in sort of go on from
there
alright so that's that let's go back to
webstorm and we're going to now talk
about setting up a script that allows us
to monitor for changes so we don't have
to restart the server so the first thing
we would do is let's stop the server
here we're going to install something
called node Mon now there is an alias
for install I could just use I instead
of install and node Mon is what I want
to install now prior to NPM v you had to
specify things like save which would
save it as a dependency in package jason
however in this case because we're using
the latest node version NPM version we
don't need to do that but node 1 is
something we're going to run during
development only so we would specify
either save - dev or
there's a shortcut for or a short for it
which is - D they both do the same thing
so what that's going to do is create a
dev dependencies section here in package
Jason and those dependencies are
only available during development time
so basically if you were to deploy this
through a CI system like circle CI it's
going to do npm install when it
downloads the project and all that is
going to do is install dev dependencies
all right so we have node one created
here what we're going to do is learn how
to use it actually let's just put it in
a let's create a command here so we're
gonna call it start watch and all we
have to do is know it Mon and point it
to a specific folder here actually you
can just do the file in this case and so
we can run it with npm run remember we
need to run this time because it's not
the start or test command and then
that's going to monitor this specific
file for changes you can also specify
folders to be monitored and things like
that and it's going to internally run
the startup file and monitor a set of
folders these are things you can look up
in the documentation as you get
acquainted with these various libraries
alright so let's go back to the slides
again sorry this requires me to switch
things around a bit so we we talked
about a get request next let's focus on
a couple other attributes that can be
passed through so I'm going to go back
to webstorm here into the person GS file
so we're going to create a couple more
routes around person itself so what I'm
going to do is copy and paste this down
here and
one of the things that we want to be
able to do is let's see pass in an
additional sort of sub route that can be
mapped to a variable so let's call it a
name and we need to specify a colon
before it so Express knows that it needs
to map that to a variable and this these
variables here are available through the
request object in a property called
params so let's just print that out here
I'm going to put a comma there we can do
request dot params dot name I'm going to
loop sorry I thought this was
console.log but I'm gonna change this to
a template so I'm going to do the back
ticks that allows me to treat this as a
variable in my state string here and I
will close it with the back thing so
that basically is the same as doing you
have requested a person plus space plus
this all right so let's save this and
notice that our server automatically
restarted so we're going to go to
insomnia and I'm going to create another
route here I'm gonna duplicate this by
right-clicking and they can duplicate
and then let's call this get person by
name and all I have to do in their route
here now when as I switch between these
it's choosing the right so it's showing
you the output for whatever is stored
there so when I when I make changes to
get person by name it's not gonna affect
person so I can go ahead and do that
here and let's call it I let's give it a
name here and then I'm gonna click send
and so it's simply responding back with
the parameter that we passed in alright
the other thing we can do is so this
here is a params object or property on
the request object what I also want to
do is allow us to pass in a query string
which is a gray string is basically a
query property on the request object
alright so the way to accomplish that is
simply by checking the query object here
so let's let's say we look for a request
query dot let's call it name as well so
that's what we're gonna pass him then we
will do something there else we're going
to handle it like we were originally so
in this case I'm going to copy this
thing over here again from line 16 do
line 7 and I'm going to replace params
with query that's the only difference
really so what this allows me to do is
basically pass called something like
localhost 3,000 slash person with what's
called a query string so anything after
the question mark is basically a part of
the query string and it's a key value
pair so I could essentially add
additional key values here by at adding
an ampersand so let's say name age
equals 20 so this you know we're not
doing anything interesting right now
we're simply echoing whatever's passed
in but this is what that allows and in
case of params
this allows us to do something like this
localhost 3000 slash person slash name
so that's the difference here in between
the two this is part of the route and
that is part of the query string alright
so I'm going to save this and let's go
back to insomnia and in the get person
piece I guess we can duplicate this as
well again and then I'll call it good
person by query string and so all I have
to do here now is specify the name and
click send there you go
so we have three ways of accomplishing
the same thing or I'm sorry two ways
here by specifying parameter so there's
my query string and by params so I'm
gonna rename this just to meet get clear
so there get person my params alright
okay so hopefully this is clear enough
so far moving on
so we talked about middleware and we set
up a middleware earlier called static
which is part of Express the middleware
are simply functions that are executed
back-to-back or serially in the request
pipeline so when a request comes in
there are a bunch of functions think of
it as an array of functions and they
execute from the index 0 all the way to
the end and each one calls when it's
done calls into the next function it has
the ability to also modify the request
and response objects and pass in
additional details downstream or it can
also decide to respond and not call into
other functions downstream because
maybe the incoming request was meant to
be handled by that function so I think I
covered through all these things here
and yeah so let's go in ahead and look
at some code and see how to do that so
the easiest middleware for us to set up
is to log every request that comes in so
we're going to accomplish that by going
into index GS and note that the order in
which these handlers are added matters
because that's how these middleware
functions are pushed onto the the array
and executed in that same order so it's
possible that person route sort of is
the function that is supposed to serve
the request and it ends up ending the
restrain of functions that are called so
we we want to actually print out the
incoming request as the first thing so
that we can catch everything that comes
in so we do that by calling app dot use
and we're going to set up a function
right in place and middleware functions
take three parameters you have the
request in response just like the other
routes that we created but there's also
something called next which is a
reference to the next function in the
pipeline
and in this case let's just console.log
a few things here I'm going to use the
back ticks again let's put in a variable
here and I'm going to create a new date
object and I'm going to call to string
on it which will print a long version of
the date and time I believe and then
we're going to also let's say list out
the URL that was requested which is
under the original URL attribute of the
request object and we can in the future
we'll modify this after a few more
changes so I I saved this and what I'm
going to do oh the thing I forgot here
is that we need to call next after we're
done otherwise it's going to break the
chain of functions that are called in
that pipeline and essentially if I
wanted to just respond from here I would
do something like respond response dot
send it is one way to sort of respond
back and then not call next
and that'll bake the pipeline however if
I don't respond to it and I don't call
next then the user is going to be
waiting for that request until it times
out so we have to make sure that we call
next here remove the response in all
right so what's going to happen here is
basically we're going to see things
printed out here sorry I'm just doing a
look at what's going on here that's
probably from what we had up there I'm
going to clear my console and let's go
ahead and make a request in insomnia so
I'm just gonna call the same route again
and go back to webstorm and notice that
there is a a line that's been out but
here which prints the the the long form
of the daytime
and the URL that was requested so there
you go I mean this is a very powerful
concept because now you can inject
functions that do things for every route
in the system and you can choose to
ignore it and not do anything and then
just pass the control along to the next
function in the pipeline all right so
I'm going back to our slides here so
another thing we can do with these
middleware is handle 404 and 500 errors
and other errors and things like that
and so let's let's go through how that's
done we're going to respond back for 404
let's say with some content initially a
string and then we can I can also show
you how to do respond with a specific
file all right so for a 404 handler all
you need to do is add a a middleware
function towards the end of the chain so
the expressed thoughts static is the
last thing we have in our chain at the
moment and so I'm going to add a middle
bit of function here that's going to
take the same request response and next
parameters and essentially what this is
is is a handler for the error 404 not
found our resource not found
and what we're gonna do here is respond
with a status code that says 404 and
we're going to send a message so we
think you are lost all right so let's go
ahead and test that all we have to do is
let's go to Chrome in this case and
let's let's just put in anything any
random string here and hit enter and
there you go what happened here was
basically there were no middleware
functions to handle that request
sorry I missed a question here the
question is anecdotally is using the IDs
terminal slower than running terminal as
a separate app so I don't think so
it really comes down to what you are
most comfortable with and most efficient
with I always shoot to sort of improve
my my sort of agility and so depends on
you know various factors and in this
case it's easier for me to stay within
the context of the ID so that I see
things that are happening right there
because I could have a build process I
could have a a test process and then
various things right there and I
wouldn't have to switch between Windows
but essentially that's something you
could do as well well I I do use a
separate terminal window when I'm using
vias code because I don't like being
integrated terminal there so there is no
sort of right answer here it's it's
really your preference I don't think
either of them are slow all right
so we handle 404 now we're going to
handle over 500 and what that means is
we're going to add another handler here
so and your 4 or 500 and so we're going
to do apt and use now the only
difference here is that this takes in
error objects it has four parameters
compared to the three that we've been
using so far and essentially we're going
to let's say we're going to print out
the error to the console so there is a
property call stack and then we're going
to let's do something different here
we're going to go to public the public
folder and create a file here and let's
call that file 500 HTML and so will
simply print something went wrong all
right I'm gonna save that file close it
and then we want to serve this file as
the response instead of some text
message so one of the things I need is
to reference the path module
and then I hope you saw that and then go
down here and we need to use the send
file method that Express provides us and
we're going to pass the join a couple of
things one is the route of the folder
which is reference to with durn
underscore underscore der name and I'm
sorry that is where the project is
running from so the main index file is
under source routes and so we're going
to go up to I'm sorry it's not source
routes it's under source so we're going
to go up to public which is one folder
above and then we're going to serve
500hp ml I think on that right yeah so
essentially indexes here the dot dot
will tell it to go up to the root and
then we're going down to public in five
hundred HTML and we're combining that
Pat and then Express we'll look at look
up the file reading the contents and
send those out with setting the right
headers and things like that all right
so I saved that and now let's say we did
the only way for us to to trigger that
is through an error so what I'm going to
do is let's go back to the routes file
and we're going to create a route here
that's going to generate an error for us
so I'm going to call it slash person
slash error and we're going to do
request response so in this handler all
we're going to do is throw a new error
so what's that what's gonna happen is
anytime we call this endpoint it's gonna
trigger some exception and since it's
not handled it's going to end up in this
part and in the 500 error handler all
right so I'm gonna save that and then go
back to our browser here and then slash
person slash error so there you go
I think that's what I printed here
oh we're not responding with that
specific error I think oh I see what's
going on here sorry let's let's call
this something else I'm just gonna call
this slash error for now because it's
conflicting with the other routes here
my apologies so that saved it I'm gonna
go back and we're simply going to type
in slash error and so there you go there
it's going through the error but it
doesn't seem to find the file we're
looking for so I believe I did something
wrong here all right let's go take a
look at what's going on here so in send
file I'm joining their name dot slash
well I made a mistake here
I need slash public so I find one at
HTML so let's retry that so going back
here to the browser I'm gonna refresh
that and there you go it's serving the
content from that file specifically that
we created so we created that method so
I could demonstrate how over 500 would
work because it only gets triggered when
there's an error all right so back to
this the slides here and so we've dealt
with error pages now let's make this a
little more interesting we have
an instance of MongoDB that we created
in M lab I'm assuming everyone's created
that if not you can try that out later
but do in order to connect to to MongoDB
we're going to use something called
Mongoose which is an ORM or an OD M
it's basically an object data mapper so
it allows us to define a model in our
application and then store that as is in
the database and that's one of the
advantages of MongoDB because you can
store JSON documents directly without
having to define relationships between
tables and things like that so there are
pros and cons to it but I've been able
to build most applications without
sequel databases in the past few years
mainly because you're able to scale your
application in many ways it's it may not
be the most efficient database out there
but it certainly simplifies your
development process significantly anyway
so let's get connected mongoose
connected we're gonna do something
similar to what we did with express so
we're gonna install the dependency and
we're going to reference it and then
we're going to focus on creating a kraut
api so essentially we're going to define
a model in Mongoose and then we're going
to perform the crud operations on that
model via the restful endpoints that we
create so let's get back into the code
all right so I'm going to so notice when
we ran into that error it also ended up
printing the stack to the console
because if this line 24 here I'm going
to stop the server
clear the console I'm gonna npm install'
mongoose alright and what we're going to
do is create a folder under source
called moppets and on the models let's
go ahead and create a model called let's
make it a bit different from person
let's call it customer so I'm going to
create a JavaScript file you know we'll
call it customer dot model yes I usually
follow this pattern for naming
conventions I separate multiple words
with a period and I always keep them
lowercase that way it makes it very
simple across larger teams so you don't
have to think about how to name files
and stuff like that alright so let's go
ahead and construct this model here so
the first thing we want to do is
reference Mongoose you already installed
it so that should be available there and
then we're going to we're going to
connect to the database in this file
itself but ideally it's something that
you can take out of this violin and have
a separate database GS file which will
do the connection to the database when
the application starts but in the
essence of time I'm just gonna do it
here so let's set up some properties for
the database so in my case I have this
written down here I'm just gonna copy
and paste it essentially I have four
attributes here pointing to my database
server the name of the database the
username and password now this is my
instance in M lab
and so if you go to your database and
since an M lab it should give you an
option to see all these attributes and
the connection string so the next thing
I want to do is connect Mongoose to the
data bees and this is something we want
to do only once at the beginning of the
program so I'm gonna use back tags and
here's the connection string you will
get this from M lab as well but it's
it's fairly straightforward so you go
start with MongoDB colon slash slash and
then we're going to specify the user
colon password at server slash database
so that would be server slash database
all right so that should generate the
the URI for connecting to the database
and finally let's create so Mongoose has
two main components to it the first is a
schema and the second is called a model
which is simply a higher-order function
that wraps around the schema really it
provides you with additional methods
that you can use to make database
queries and things like that
so let's define a customer schema next
and the way you do that is by creating a
new instance of mongoose schema and let
me sorry if you were not able to read
this there you go
so within the customer schema that we're
defining let's create a couple of
attributes there we're gonna create an
attribute called name and we're gonna
tell it that the type is string and then
the next thing is let's create something
called email let's
instead of assigning it directly to
string I'm going to show you a couple
other things you can do here
so we can also assign a an object as a
value there and define additional
properties on there so we're going to
tell it that the type here is a string
and then it's required property and that
it has to be unique that way we don't
end up with duplicates and this
validation was actually done on the
application layer itself so [ __ ]
database is not doing the validation
there that's the advantage of using
Mongoose because [ __ ] is key Milus and
unless you explicitly configure some
rules in MongoDB it does not do any
validation all right so now we have the
customer schema we're going to create a
model and export it at the same time so
we're gonna do module dot exports equals
Mongoose they're our model and then the
first attribute is going to be the name
of the model and then followed by the
reference to the schema object okay so
let's do a quick recap here we
referenced Mongoose I defined some
attributes some variables here that help
us construct the database connection
string and then we're connecting to the
database and we're defining a customer
schema we have two attributes in their
name which is a simple string and the
email attribute has additional
properties on it which sorry I missed D
here so it's supposed to be required so
essentially we're telling you that it
needs to be any and it it must be
present and that finally we exported as
a mongoose model
all right so I'm going to save this and
we're going to create a route that's
going to expose crud operations and
we're going to reference this customer
model and then make some entries in the
database and retrieve those and things
like that so I'm gonna go into the
routes folder and then create a
JavaScript file called I just got a
customer GS and I'm gonna switch the
person quickly
essentially this is what we want to do
we're just going to have to type it sort
of all over again but let's do it from
scratch so we're going to start out with
referencing the customer model so let's
do let customer model equals require and
it's one folder above slash models slash
customer done model and then we also
want to reference Express
and then we want to reference create the
router instance from that Express
reference all right so let's let's
create a route that will allow us to
create a new customer so here we'll
create a new customer and we're going to
create what's called a post
and notice that the the type of
operation you're trying to define that
the verb itself is available as a method
in Express so on post we're gonna call
it slash customer so what this will
allow us to do is call in to localhost
3000 slash customer and we're going to
make the post request to it and then
there's a handler with request response
that we're going to deal with here so
one of the things we need to do is when
we're passing in the data for creating
the customer object we have we're going
to pass it in the body as a JSON object
now Express does not know how to handle
that by default so we need to tell it
what to do with it so essentially we're
going to go back to index GS and there
is a package we need to install for it
called body parser and so let's go into
the console and we're going to do NPM
install body - part of our server and
what that's going to do is essentially
look at the incoming requests and if it
is if the content type of that request
is application slash Jason basically
that that means that the data in the
body is a JSON string the in that case
the body parser will
we'll take that string convert it to
Jason and right I'll create a property
in the request object called body and
then set the value there so essentially
it's doing the work for us to parse that
piece out so let's see how that works
here so we're going to reference body
parser and we're going to let's do this
as the first thing coming in mainly
because then we can print whatever is
being sent in our logger there all right
so we're gonna do app that use and in
this case we wanted to use the Jason
module so it's essentially taking in any
incoming Jason string and creating an
attribute called body
so essentially what that lets us do is I
can also we can also print the body if
any that's converted by this body parser
alright so I'm gonna save that and then
go back to our customer GS file so what
happens here is that now we have access
to request our body before adding the
body parser that didn't exist so we
would have to look at the raw data and
then the content type and then you know
if it was Jason and all that stuff then
we'd have to kind of extract the right
pieces and and end up constructing that
some body parser is taking care of that
for us
that's the power of Express it has so
many different kinds of plugins in
middleware that most of your application
can be composed of these middleware
libraries and you can of course write
your own in certain cases so and in this
case what we want to do is let's make
sure that request our body exists so
we're going to first check for that
and that comment and essentially oops if
it does not exist we want to return a
response with a status code of 400 which
means it's a bad request and send a
string with that response and let's say
we tell it that request body is missing
so the the recipient the caller sort of
knows what's wrong exactly here in terms
of these status messages there's
obviously a package out there
I think it's called HTTP status which
has a bunch of these status codes
defined as enumerations so you could
refer to it by the text name itself
instead of the number and I would
recommend using that in a real-world
project now if the body is present
though now we want to create an instance
of the customer model and save it to the
database so let's do that here with
referencing the customer model and
request so we're gonna pass in whatever
oops was a part of the request body and
construct that model there essentially
what we're gonna pass here is something
like this let say user equal to we need
a name you know so this was the first
name last name whatever and then email
you know you know like the incoming
object is gonna be something like this
so that's what we're gonna pass through
over here and we'll get through how to
send that as well in insomnia all right
so the next thing I want to do is save
that model and essentially that will
communicate from Mongoose to the [ __ ]
driver which is going to then talk to
[ __ ] database and tell it to take these
details the
the request of body object and validated
via the customer model and save it to
the database so we're going to use
promises here to sort of follow up on
this request so after we save we're
going to call then and then is going to
I believe respond with the document that
it saved and so what we're gonna do is
if we weren't able to save the document
or it's an array of documents I believe
or if document length is zero then we
want to respond with an error so let's
see it's an internal server error we're
going to send that document we should be
null in this case or an empty array and
if that's not the case then we want to
respond with the status code of 201
which stands for resource was created
now this is a sort of optional in a way
you could have responded with 200 as
well but that that's where so the rest
sort of defines the guidelines you know
for how things should be constructed
that's up to you as the programmer as
the developer to to figure out it to
design the system and figure out what
these response codes will be and then
you need to document it as part of your
API that people will use to access your
your restful api so here I'm going to
respond back with the document that we
just created and then finally we can
also catch any exceptions and so there
were any errors those will be caught
here and so we'll sort of do the same
thing as above respond with an error
code there and then instead of saying
we're going to call Jason which is going
to take in the error object and and
transform it and send it over instead of
a specific message this kind of gives us
more details now it's up to you how you
want to respond
you know in your projects and stuff
alright so that should complete the
customer creation process I'm assuming
who done everything right here let's run
the project here via NPM run start watch
all right so it's up and running we're
going to switch over to insomnia and
we're going to create a new request I'm
going to call it post customer and I
accidently set it to get here but we're
gonna switch that over to a post and
then I'm going to call in to our
endpoint here customer and let's see
what happens if I click send so we get
an error there and guess what we forgot
to add this to the routes here so we
need to reference that I'm gonna get rid
of the spaces here so that these are
sort of organized nicely so we're going
to reference the let's do it right by
this other around here we're gonna
public customer route equals require dot
slash routes slash customer and then
we're gonna tell it to use the rod here
as well so we it's going to register
that and you need to be careful about
the order as well essentially you could
mess things up by having an incorrect
order where something might be returning
earlier than you expect to do anyway
I think this so sometimes a node Mon
will crash and it may not restart so at
that point what you can do is in your
console you can type in RS which tells
it to restart and what's happening over
here line 16 it does not like this
because I think I missed something here
in customer GS yep so we're not
I believe we're not exporting that
router so that's what we want to do here
so module dot exports equals router
there you go now it's going to looking
so server started now so a couple of
things we had missed one was to export
the module and the other was to actually
import it and then tell Express to to
register those routes so let's go back
to insomnia and okay so we're gonna
click send here again so notice earlier
that said we think you are lost that's
because it did not recognize that route
and it and the 404 handler the the
resource not found handler kicked in and
you can see her the error code that was
sent back so let's click send here again
now I get an internal server error and
it's giving us some details here so we
had responded with the entire error
object we could have simply responded
with let's say the message here but in
our case we were showing the we were
returning everything so we know what's
going on here so let's change things
around here in this post request so the
body part I'm gonna click on the drop
down here is going to be of type Jason
and then in in there we're going to pass
in an object which has name let's call
Thomas Anderson and then we have an
email now if I omitted the email it
would still complain about it too
because it's going to validate on the
server side so let's call it almost at
gmail.com and essentially I can when I
click send here it says 201 created and
it's going to be responding with what
Creek had created internally it's
generating an ID for it as well and it
also tracks the version as you update
the object alright so that was it and
for creating the the entry in the
database let's verify by going to Robo
three T now assuming you've connected
everything here we're going to have a
collection called customers
Express will I'm sorry Mongoose will
PluralEyes model names so customer ends
up becoming customers I'm going to
double click this and that opens a new
tab there and there you go it's going to
show you a record that was created so we
had added these entries in there when we
posted to the route so there you go that
was that simple I'm sure you may not
remember a few things at this point but
that is okay you know a little bit of
practice and then looking through
documentation and other tutorials will
definitely help you understand this
better so let's go back to the customer
route I'm going to go to the post here
and so we were ensuring that a body was
present we could have also sorted
checked for other attributes being
present so as part of body we could have
checked something like if not request
our body dot email right and then I
could have done something here and
responded however the customer model is
actually validating some of that for us
so if things were missing here that the
customer model expected like email for
instance then this cache block would be
triggered and we would still get an
error so that's one of the advantages of
using Mongoose anyway so let's quickly
add a couple other methods here so we're
going to next add the ability to
retrieve this data so we're going to
create an endpoint called customer to
get the customer they now have the same
format here again request response and
one of the things we're gonna do here is
we're expecting an email so we're going
to look up the customer via email so
we're gonna create we're gonna actually
use the customer model directly and the
model gives us a few methods on it that
allow us to search through a query
through the content in this case so
we're going to call a method call find
one and Mongoose has a very rich API
it has a ton of functions that
definitely are way out of scope for this
workshop but I would encourage you to
look at their documentation there are
also lots of interesting articles out
there that'll highlight some of those
but anyway in this case we're gonna use
find one and find one takes an object
with attributes as the query parameter
so in this case we're gonna pass in the
email which is we're expecting via query
email for instance and then of course we
want to make sure that it exists up here
so we're going to check for requests our
query in an email if that's not present
we're going to respond with respond with
a status code of 400 resource I'm sorry
400 isn't there and we're going to tell
that it's missing URL parameters so
let's do send I'm just saying URL
parameter email that's required so
that's gonna exit out of there if not we
should also have our document available
on on the den method that gets called
and what we can do is respond to the
request with that document if there is
an error we want to handle that here in
the catch block and essentially respond
back with the status quo to 500 with
this error object and that should return
the model there and when you quickly add
a couple of these other methods since
we're almost out of time here so the the
other is put that allows us to update
the existing customer and all these have
a similar format what I'm going to do is
I will copy some of these elements here
and then just paste it there essentially
I could I could use some of this reuse
some of that so we have request response
and in this body here we're going to
actually need the email piece as well so
we're gonna check that there is an email
present in the query if not we're going
to call a method on the model called
fine one and update and essentially it's
going to query based of this and then it
takes another parameter which is your
body in this case so let's call into
that that would be request body and
whoops body and then you know you can
pass an options object in this case the
options basically one of the options
we're going to pass that is to return
the newly created or updated object
otherwise it returns the same it would
return the same request body that you
sent in but since we want to make sure
that the change actually went through we
want to do that set that attribute I
have a typo here so I'm chained that to
status and then so this was your post
request this is your get request and
then this is your update request so the
you in the crud and
or I have a few typos here all right so
that that will update the existing
object we match on the email and then
finally we want to be able to delete so
that would be router delete and again
very similar to this I'm just gonna copy
paste that part of the code as well so
essentially you're calling into customer
we're gonna make sure that email exists
and then there is a method called find
one and remove which will take in your
email and then we don't need the request
body and the new pieces from above that
we copied and everything else here stays
the same again
alright so I think that that covers the
basic crud operations and let's go into
insomnia and test it so let's go down
let's make sure the terminal is still
okay the project is still working fine
I'm gonna switch over to insomnia and
then I'm going to duplicate this and
call it put customer and essentially
this method should be put and we're
expecting a query string called email so
we're gonna pass an email equals Thomas
at gmail.com and then we're gonna send
in the body here let's call it Thomas
updated Andersen and we're going to
click send here and there you go it
responded with an okay and if you notice
the the object that it responded with is
the newly created object I think I made
a mistake earlier when I mentioned that
it responds with requests our body what
I meant to say it was a response with
the original object that it it finds and
not the updated object so let's
duplicate this again and
there is we want to get customer in this
case and we're going to call that get
here
and essentially we want to get this by
again via email so let's call this
Thomas and gmail.com and then we don't
need a JSON body here so we're going to
delete that and you can leave that as is
and now if we click send here it's going
to retrieve whatever was sent in and
finally I'm gonna duplicate that again
and call this delete customer and so
change that again to delete and
essentially the query string stays the
same I should be able to hand I hit Send
and then it says ok it's responding with
what was deleted let's say if I were to
click send again it's gonna respond with
a null because that object has been
deleted already so let's verify that by
going into Robo 3 T so here I can there
are different windows you can do control
are on a Mac its command R and if i
refresh it you'll notice that the record
has disappeared now so most of those
other methods were very similar in terms
of the the restful setup as well as you
know the attributes that were coming in
and things that we were modifying and
stuff like that so let's do a quick
recap here we created a customer model
which is part of the customer model J's
file you're familiar with this by now
and so we referenced that in customer GS
that's our route and essentially we're
creating a route here the first piece is
a create operation that handled via the
post verb and it's calling into customer
we're expecting a body to be passed in
we added the reference to a body parser
middleware for Express which actually
gives us that data that's passed in the
body attribute this was just an example
here that we could check for an email to
exist on that body as well there's
obviously a lot of error handling
you can do to make this more robust and
essentially the object coming in will
look something like this that we're
simply passing through to the customer
model so we create a new instance of the
customer model with that incoming JSON
object and we call save on that model
and then basically there are two methods
here on the sorry
this is using promises so promises have
been and catch and so we're handling you
know different error conditions and then
whatnot here so this is pretty
straightforward here I think the
important piece is how to create that
route and how to respond you want to
make sure you're passing back the right
error codes and things like that or
status codes and things like that get
request was very similar you know you
change the verb here the method name
that maps to get similar things you're
just a method on your customer model
changes so essentially that was like the
the only big change between all the
other methods on the route so you have
get and an update you have fine one an
update and for delete you have fine one
and remove so I think that that about
wraps this up I think that there was a
lot of content that we cram into this
hour and a half and sorry if someone
says is a pure database person their
brain hurts I apologize it's it's a lot
of moving pieces here and if you don't
get it it's okay don't feel bad it took
me a long time to really understand this
and master it these things take time
just because of changing API is and also
that the variety of functions that they
expose so I want to do something real
quick here before we end so I'm going to
clear my console here and now we have
our application here we have a package
Jason that defines the project and the
excrement things like that
there's a service called now dot Sh
that essentially allows you to make to
deploy your node.js applications real
quick and so I will let you explore this
but what I'm going to do is simply
deploy this to the cloud now and so what
I need to do is go into my application
folder and I type in now I haven't been
now client installed your via NPM as a
global and they have all the
instructions here on this site but I
simply want to show you how easy it is
for us to get this up and running in the
cloud since I'm using the free version
it's asking me a question that's stating
that my application will be public and
so essentially what it's doing is it's
it's zipping up the application that's
making sure that there's a package Aysen
that exists it will upload that to the
server side and then it's unzipping it
and it is running the NPM install
command which ends up setting up all the
dependencies that we require for the
project and here you see it's done it's
giving you a status about what's going
on so it did a bunch of things here it's
telling you which version of no that's
using there is an actual end point that
it created for us and it's copied it to
the clipboard it's synced all the 10
files it's initializing its build
process and ran NPM install package -
lock that Jason is something new with
NPM 5 it allows you to replicate the
exact versions of libraries that you
used and then I guess it was waiting to
so internally it's it's running the NPM
start command I think one of the things
that I missed here in packages and I
want to quickly add is we want to set
the the
the process environment variable and
essentially an index es we were doing
this here for port so we want to make
sure we're setting port and it's as easy
as going in here and setting port equal
to whatever value that we would need but
anyway I think this should be deployed
already
I think it's copied but I'm gonna make
sure I copy it again and then we're
going to go to the browser and let's put
this in there let's see if that works
there you go so we quickly got our
application up and running in the cloud
and since we were using em lab you know
it's connected to the database we didn't
have to worry about uploading the
database or installing a database and
things like that of course you would
need to to have a config file that then
looks at the type of environment you're
running in development staging test
production and then use the appropriate
values from there to connect to the
appropriate databases but here you go
you can actually do this very quickly
and play with it once you have your
application up and running there was a
question here it says do you usually
need to use Mongoose to access a MongoDB
and the answer is no you don't that the
new MongoDB driver is definitely a lot
more powerful lately
where it allows you to do validations as
well you can define a lot of those
things several people prefer that
approach I personally have been using
Mongoose for a while so I stick with it
because I'm familiar with the API and it
provides us with a lot of rich methods
to to handle these these interfaces into
the database and I can also abstract my
models out and add specific methods on
it to do more complex operations and so
it's sort of provided a very good
plug-in model for that and so yeah the
answer is no you don't have to use
Mongoose but it just simplifies a lot of
the process there I did write a couple
of articles that might be useful one of
them was introduction to Mongoose
I don't know if I can introduction to
Mongoose there this one specifically
walks you through you know how to use
Mongoose for MongoDB and check it out
see what do you think of it there's also
another one I have called building your
how to build your own react boilerplate
this kind of introduces react into the
mix but it also walks you through some
of these basic building blocks for
creating you know Express servers and
things like that the idea was that most
people start out with using some
existing boilerplate like create react
app for instance but they don't
understand the underlying building
blocks and that was the idea here to
break it down into individual pieces so
you understand what's going on now this
one of course uses web pack version 3 so
I do plan on updating it with version 4
which is a lot easier in case you're
planning on reading this anyway
I think that about wraps it up I
apologize for going 10 minutes over here
I think yeah that was it
if you have any additional questions
please feel free to reach out directly
to me or on dev - you can follow me on
twitter at the outlander and I hope this
was worth your time I hope you get to
play with this further and make sure you
explore all the api's look up the
documentation for Express for Mongoose
check out now TSH which will allow you
to deploy your application very quickly
compared to you know EWS and even Heroku
is pretty fast but now just takes it to
a whole new level where all you type is
now and it gives you this URL with your
application and you can map a domain
name to it directly and scale very
easily and I have used a ton of cloud
providers and I absolutely love now and
would highly recommend it already thank
you so much I'm going to pause the
session here
and hope to hear from you soon bye-bye